the the bay is like it's it's made of  like it's massive yeah it's big but it's  like it's like a hella small cities and  small pockets that like all  combine and meet each other but yeah  like together there's some there there's  certain [ __ ] that you know that sounds  like it's from the the surface club you  know what i'm saying or some [ __ ] that  sounds like oakland and some [ __ ] that  sounds like all this some valet [ __ ] but  now it's just like but it's also like  there's there's these pockets of like  even people from sac you know what i'm  saying to sacramento and then like the  people in the valley like stockton and  no no stockton's booming yeah like  there's a lot of like don't [ __ ] but it  all stems from the like the bad music  you know what i'm saying like the the  essence